Justin how are you good how are you sir
better than I deserve what's up well I
am leading a SPU class and just has
something that basically quick question
for you is I am trying to figure out on
my own personal budget whether I should
not pay like certain things if there's
not enough money in our budget and pay
our tithes of course number one ten
percent or should I try and fit in the
mini credit cards I'm trying to work on
and pay off what'd I just tell them
though and I'll get your money as it
comes
so how short are you well when we had a
large food alone that went basically
doubled on us last year
well hey well monthly in your monthly
budget how short are you about 200 250
bucks roughly so why not just take a
part-time job that's what I think - is
what I'm coming in towards you I mean
call me up without what you say you know
my I'm not gonna I'm not able to pay my
bills well let's create some income my
only thing I'd also well that's true I
just don't I hate to take more time away
from my family and pay your bills dude
yeah you got it you can have to do
something I mean you can't let's go I
want to sit home with the baby so
MasterCard has to ditch it no I mean I
thought you guys have borrowed yourself
into a mess so you're gonna have to dig
yourself out I'm not saying I'm saying
you abandon your family for life and
become a workaholic but for a period of
time here you got to get with it yeah so
you listen here's what I'm gonna do if
I'm in your shoes I'm gonna crank it up
so much that it's unbelievable so I can
clear a whole bunch of this stuff out
even faster not just merely make my
bills but start really getting some
progress and knocking them out how much
debt have you got total we've got let me
quickly say here we've got a home
student 150,000 not counting the house
our student loan is sixty-nine thousand
and then our the rest of our debt
probably equals another 40 with our
vehicles and much do in your car I owe
4000 on one vehicle and 11 on another
and what's your household income
household income would be about 35 yeah
you got 35 sorry sorry in 75 Oh better
okay you're gonna have to get your
income up though you're right and I
don't hear anything here that's out of
line except you guys need to get on that
written budget really crank the
lifestyle down to nothing and you are
not to work some extra to get you in you
know to start to knock some of these
things out
you got one hundred nine thousand bucks
making 75 you got to pay off it's gonna
take you four years of really tough work
but you can do it hey you guys bracelet
crews here hope you are enjoying the
Dave Ramsey show if you didn't know I
actually have my own YouTube channel so
I do videos twice a week on life and
money so you can click the subscribe
button to subscribe to my channel and
you want to check out our video right
now check out the video on how to make a
budget
[Music]